none of us in here are can be considered
traditional women and back then an
average guy could get a traditional
woman and now what does he get he gets a
boss [ __ ] a boss babe a girl that's
been ran through he gets an ex-ho he
gets a born-again virgin like this is as
as women this is what what do we get we
still get protection and provisioning
are you sure and average the average
time
I mean okay okay here's here's the thing
the average salary could cover an
apartment
and but the thing is like women we want
this lifestyle that's not even realistic
nowadays like we want men that make more
than we do and we want them to pay all
of the bills but it's like we work we
all have our nails done we have
um we get our hair dyed we have makeup
we have all of this stuff that costs
money because we want this lifestyle and
I've had girls come on my show and I say
would you would you date an average guy
for a companionship but you would have
to go down in lifestyle and they say no
we're addicted to Lifestyle